[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney is my co-host this hour
here on the ramsey show this is a show
where we help you build wealth do work
that you love and have high quality
amazing relationships and mental
wellness we're here to help you with all
of that join us the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two
it is launch week for dr john dolone's
brand new book own your past change your
future a not so complicated approach to
relationships and mental health
absolutely incredible tomorrow is actual
launch day so if you order by midnight
tonight you get all the goodies and that
includes um the audiobook and the e-book
and a
month of weekly therapy with the fine
folks at better help you got to order
today by midnight tonight the phone
number is aaa or just go to
ramseysolutions.com
for the book own your past change your
future
john
how's it feel to be one day out
i was feeling good and and uh
it's like having a baby we're inducing
labor tomorrow that's happening and uh
yeah driving down the highway and seeing
my face on a billboard i wasn't prepared
for that
it's weird that's so weird it's weird
i thought my daughter looked at me as
though i grew three heads like dad what
are you doing up there that's
embarrassing that's exactly right yeah
yeah i said oh honey
that's embarrassing she'll be doing that
that's probably as long as you live
that's exactly right yeah
yeah the first time i ever got a
billboard there was me and another guy
that were doing a radio show we just
started this radio show in nashville
only
and they figured out at the billboard
company that if you do an extension
meaning that like an arrow going out the
side of the billboard or something
sticking out outside the square
that it catches the eye more yeah and so
they figured out they needed an
extension so these geniuses decided that
the extension was going to be my bald
head sticking up
so there's this little half moon
sticking up so we drive over we're all
so thrilled we have a billboard and uh i
shouldn't tell this but it's the truth
it happened so we drive over there
sharon and i we're gonna go get a
picture i got a picture of the billboard
it's classic
and so we drive over there to hickory
hollow mall which is not there anymore
now and uh find the billboard there by
the side of the interstate and there's
my head sticking up half moon above it
and three birds sitting on it
we couldn't get a good picture because i
got birds sitting on my bald head up
there it was awful so just in case you
thought you'd made it hey i want to say
god god will bring you a little humility
slick digital board man it looks good
you're on you're on a digital board with
no birds yeah and it changes every four
or five minutes that's not you it's not
me that's the other thing is on there
yeah so yeah we put those up around
nashville just to announce that we're
very proud of this book yeah i'm excited
man national best-selling author dr john
dolone his brand new book his first
major trade book
and uh we are really really excited
about this let's talk about what it is
because it is launch week and uh
what do i get if i'm reading this book
what's your hope what's your dream for
the reader my hope is that most of us
have just come to understand and believe
that life is just quote-unquote just
gonna be like this i was just talking to
somebody who i love and care about and
she was walking me through some
challenges her and her husband's a best
friend of mine they're struggling with
this and this and
and they just like well i guess this is
the way this is and some of the wisdom
they've received is you just got to suck
it up you've got to cope just going to
be this way and
i just reject that dave i think there's
a different way to live and if we
understand why we've arrived at where we
are and then have some steps to get out
of this thing and start doing life
differently man it affects our kids our
marriages our job it affects every part
of our lives and so my goal here is um
again
i i can't
sit 101 with everybody right not
everybody's got my cell number
if i was to sit down with somebody this
is what i would tell you like how to own
the stuff that happened and how to make
the next right the horrible things that
have been there the good things that
have been there in your past i'll own
them yeah you we tell stories is the
framework of the book uh to ourselves
and then the trick is to
you know make the story real uh because
sometimes in our head we make uh what
happened to us the thing
yeah the story's on us rather than a
thing that's right and here dave i don't
know if you know i've talked about this
but
we've been given two paths forward
in life
either you're the worst thing that ever
happened to you you're the worst thing
that um
of your life that's all you'll ever be
is this i'm the guy i found bankruptcy
when i was 28. that's all you'll be and
if that's you then somebody's got to
come save you there has to be some
government program to come drag you out
of this because you're a loser you're
always going to be busted that's it and
the other narrative we've been given is
if you have a feeling it's a it's a it's
a sign of weak character you're a fool
suck it up move on just plow through
life and then there's a wake of hurt and
loss and so i'm calling
bull crap on both of those this is a new
third way man how to own that stuff and
then what to do on the back end well the
major thing that happened to you is not
you it's not your identity it's a thing
it's a thing that happened yes and so
horrible things have happened to people
people have gone through all kinds of
tragedies there's loss
uh and i worked there 38 years and they
fired me
uh yeah how long ago was that 15 years
ago well you're still talking about it
like it's 20 minutes ago which means
you're still living in it that's right
and you've taken it as an identity
rather than a thing that happened that's
right and that's not sucking it up and
saying there's not feelings there is
feelings but living in this perpetual
state of
grieving the thing right letting that
thing grieve you being a victim forever
yeah it owns you it defines you it tells
you you know who you are i i got
divorced when 14 years ago you're still
talking about it he left me he didn't
hate i mean my god you know it's like
wow move on really but that's hard to do
right it is it is hard to move i'm not
saying suck it up but i am saying oh
there's some suck it up too there is
there is a part of that but that's the
own your past part that is in my past
the rear view mirror is smaller than the
windshield the windshield is my future
it's grace that's right that's right
it's bigger it's a wide open
white board if i don't allow the past to
you know color the future to the point i
can't do anything that's right and if
most of us would wrap our heads around
what that could look like
we would be able to sleep a full night
of sleep without medication we'd be able
to call somebody to come over when we're
feeling low we have a group of people
that we do life with we'll be able to
laugh from our guts these basic human
things that have just been slowly
plucked out of our lives over the last
10 15 25 30 years well and you know
this idea that we can have relationships
through a digital app yeah is a is a
false thing yeah we've been and that's
damaged our culture too yeah big time
it's left us with this need for
relationships and we don't even realize
we don't have them yeah well i have 14
friends on facebook you don't have any
real friends that's right and none of
them will help you change the tire
that's exactly right one nope not one
they will thumbs down your post about
easter if it wasn't the right if you
didn't if you didn't quote it the way
that they were raised you know that's
right you got the wrong version of
scripture uh yeah own your past change
your future is the brand new book a not
so complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness it is not a
book for people struggling with extreme
mental health issues now go see your
psychiatrist psychologist yeah go see a
therapist this is a book for all the
rest of us right that have minor
or if you love somebody that you're
struggling with
or if you work next to a guy i'm just
kidding yeah it's incredible careful
this is for all of us yeah ah it's great
own your past change your future brand
new book we'll be another best seller
we're sure of that uh if you want the
deal you need to order it now at
ramseysolutions.com
before midnight and get zip guns
that was uh hillbilly french to hear it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year
netsuite gives you the visibility and
control of the things you need to grow
like your financials inventory hr
planning budgeting and more all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free whitepaper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
he's author of the brand new book that
comes out tomorrow own your past change
your future a not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness david is in canada hi david
welcome to the ramsey show
hello hi how can we help
um well we have a question about
identity um first of all both of you
thank you so much for certainly the
content you create and we're grateful
for our plan
we started in february march of 2019
with 113 000 canadian dollars worth of
debt we're around uh we're at 83 079
right now so basically 8 400. you know
the finish line is imminent and tina and
i kind of want to know like
who are we after we achieve this goal
this has been a long haul we
don't really have a strong sense of uh
where to go next
wow that's incredible so uh what got you
started on this journey that that long
ago
um
family members inappropriate gift a
family member
gave
another family member a copy of a total
money makeover
um and uh
christina and i were you know uh
sort of uh
victims of our own lifestyle creep and
we had purchased a fixer-upper
and 99 my idea
and uh it was a total total dumpster
fire um it was
by far
the
least thought out um renovation project
in ontario
you just found yourself in a hole
you better believe it
all right so you've worked together for
three years now crushing and growing it
you're about 80
500 away from the finish line what do
you guys want to do next like what do
you want to do
what do we want to do dina
live life we want to own a home at some
point um
in the sort of short term
like we're married 10 years in april of
2023 i was kind of thinking that like
disney world would be nice
okay so
if you just draw another short finish
line here you're going to just keep
jumping from finish line to finish line
i want you to do something completely
different and you've probably heard me
say this on my show a million times
um
the the best analogy i've ever heard
is
they could never go sweep up all the
glass and steel and dust from the twin
towers and rebuild those twin towers
with that dust and that same glass and
same steel
the buildings fell and it's over right
so we have to we have to excavate it
sometimes you have to go get
professionals to help you but you
excavate it and then you have to draw
what's going to be in its place
what's going to come next and it can be
negative situations or it can be really
positive things we just the last kid
just went to college and then now what
now we get to excavate what was and we
get to completely redesign what what
comes next using all of our experiences
and talents that we've got and then lean
into what's this thing going to look
like
um dave you've been taking this question
for 30 years when people get to that
finish line okay i'm debt-free and they
scream it then they go okay now now i've
still got to live with you
what have you seen that is is helpful in
help helping them rebuild reimagine
something new yeah i think you again you
set another goal but it's not a
short-term goal it's an identity goal
you mentioned the phrase identity and um
john you and i have talked offline about
our friend james clear book uh james
clear's book atomic habits and one
things he talks about with atomic habits
is you you clearly say
i i used to be a person that smoked now
i'm a non-smoker
okay
instead of i don't smoke anymore
now you you you couch the language and
identity i i used to be a person david
that borrowed money i don't borrow money
anymore um i and and i'm a person that
wants to build wealth
and be incredibly generous
and i and i want to do all the things
that wealth and
entails which is a enjoy it and b
give it and enjoy even more the
generosity of it um and that's my
reasoning for continuing to build wealth
i i have never suggested nor have i
personally done a thing where i build
wealth just for the purpose of a single
vacation or for a or for the purpose of
being wealthy
i'm not trying to be wealthy i'm trying
to do the things that wealth does and so
that's an identity i i'm a i'm a wealthy
person that enjoys money and incredible
generosity and that's my identity and i
decided that after i was a person that
went bankrupt
and so right david if you think about
identity as that new building
my wife and i we sat down years ago and
we
uh we're trying to figure out what our
marriage is going to look like what new
work was going to look like and we
actually made a it's a small
we did it like with the kid with with
our oldest son at the time but we just
made a
uh it was like a craft project basically
but it was here's who the delonies are
going to be
we're going to be people who fill in the
blood we we're people who say yes we're
people who have others over and those
decisions shaped the house that we
bought it shapes how we save money it
shapes um the jobs i did or didn't take
because it all leaned back to how do
these actions back up and support this
new identity this new building that
we're building you see what i'm saying
yeah sharon and i got as an another a
minute example of that too is um
sharon and i it took us a little while
to realize we
are not people who enjoy
uh passive vacations
we don't sit
right where we go
so if we're if we're going to africa
we're going to go all over the place and
see every freaking animal
you know we're not going to sit and hope
the animal wanders by
you know i mean we're out there hunting
them with a camera right and so uh
we're in action and so we plan
the the vacations in that regard other
people want to go and sit and put their
feet in the sand and read a book and
never move uh i can do that at home
personally so i don't do that but but we
just that's a nuanced thing we decided
and both of us enjoy that type of travel
and so when we're booking travel it's
action-oriented travel but to reverse
engineering or event travel you start
taking golf lessons right and because i
want to be out moving and doing things
so i'm going to learn how to do this
thing so it it impacted your actions on
a day-to-day basis
for these things later on right and i'm
a guy who
i naturally in the evening when i'm at
home and someone says hey let's come
back out let's let's we're going to go
grab something to eat we're going to
watch the fights my inclination is i'm
just going to sit here
but i had said i'm going to be a guy who
says yes to things who goes on
adventures and so i dragged myself out
i'm going to get you you're a guy that
used to be in debt david now you're a
guy that is getting out of debt and now
you're a guy the next step is you're a
guy that doesn't borrow money yep
i used to but i don't borrow money
anymore i used to smoke i don't smoke
anymore i i didn't but i mean that's
what clear talks about the that's right
changing the language that and that
states the identity and that's not
positive thinking it's observation i am
no longer that person that's right i am
now this person i i think the the
positive thinking movement
that goes with your book that's exactly
right
in fact i i talk about that one of the
chapters yeah own your passion for the
future yeah is creating this this
identity moving forward and so david
i see this as a moment like one of the
few moments in your adult life and
you'll do this you know four five six
times
when you get to plan and shape what this
thing looks like and it's going to be
loosely held of course but
what a cool exercise to go spend a half
day retreat with your wife and say okay
we're not running for our lives anymore
what do we want this thing to look like
yeah now i'm a person that doesn't eat
63 donuts yeah i was unbelievably fat
during covent
but i'm not anymore and i'm not going to
self-identify as a person who eats every
donut in a 50-mile radius i have done it
in the past but i cannot do that because
i get as big as this room i look like
the marshmallow and for for lent i gave
up sugar this year which was a battle
you know that was hard but
instead of saying i'm not i'm not i'm
not yeah i said i'm a guy who doesn't
need sugar right and i just didn't dave
and i wish i could tell you why or it
was a light switch for me yeah i just
don't there's something about the
language change that end well out of the
abundance of the heart the mouth speaks
that's it man so it's biblical but the
uh
this idea that you reset your mind and
you go
i used to be a person that
did that but i'm now i'm this person now
i'm a pro i don't i'm a person doesn't
borrow money and i'm pursuing wealth for
the purpose of enjoyment and generosity
and changing my family tree
you know what an identity man yeah and
so you just give yourself a different
way of looking at things and and you can
do that at 84 years old and you can do
it at 24 years old it's not an age thing
it's a decision thing congratulations
really good question way to go david by
the way way to go
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr chondaloni ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage ally is
with us hey ali how are you i'm doing
well how are you better than i deserve
where do you live in minnesota cool what
part um kind of like west central
minnesota it's a little town called
bluffton it's like 200 people wonderful
welcome to nashville and all the way to
tennessee to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off i paid off uh 59
078.38
cool how long did this take you um 13
months and three days
look at you
and your range of income during that
year um well so i started at 58 000
gross and then um when i was done i was
making about 99 000 and then now i make
about 120. whoa what do you do for a
living wow um i'm a labor and delivery
nurse oh good for you yeah okay you get
the award for most sparkly debt-free
screens thank you
what is the deal with the spark please
tell me that's your lab coat
i wish that would be awesome if i could
wear this to work you could deliver a
baby in that that would be awesome i
know
the people of women
hallucinating yeah disco that's it yeah
exciting uh no i just really like
glitter okay so yeah i um i saw it
walking past the store
i thought maybe you came to nashville
and it got out of control no no this is
my normal okay
you got on a pedal tavern dave and then
all of a sudden that's it yeah
yeah that's what happens when you get on
a pedal to everyone in the nashville
no it's cool i love it it's very nice
very nice appropriate so what happened
13 months ago that put you on this
journey this debt-free journey tell us
your story yeah well actually it starts
more like high school my parents went
through some pretty rough financial
times and then um they
took a financial piece university and uh
we're kind of dave-ish but they always
talk to me about like don't get any
credit cards and um so you're a
financial piece baby-ish yes yes i know
i was like i think ish probably but yeah
so i um i was always like
you know i tracked my spending i didn't
necessarily have a budget that i stuck
to but um i
was really hardcore about it my junior
year of college like the summer between
my sophomore and junior year because i
was saving up to go to costa rica
because i studied abroad there for four
months and
i got really burnt out like i just was
like i don't ever want to do this again
it was terrible because i was working
every single day
and so then
fast forward um i met david my fiance
and
he was like he was debt-free and he's
like oh but it's so awesome you know
think about when we get married we could
go and be debt-free and you know yeah
just change our family tree and i'm like
i did that once before and i don't
really want to do that again because it
was horrible um but then i just one day
i just remember thinking about all the
things that i could do if i didn't have
this debt hanging over my head what kind
of debt was it um i had student loans
from two bachelor's degrees and then um
a car loan okay so yeah but yeah i just
i remember standing too october 13th
2020 i was in my kitchen and i was like
what am i doing like i make so much
money and i
i have the potential to make more money
too i'm a nurse you know and so i just
decided right then and there that i was
like i'm going to do this and yeah i
told david i was like i'm doing it i'm
doing the dave ramsey debt snowball you
know so i just decided and just
went from there so looked up the
materials again and yeah i have actually
dialed it in or what yeah i i've read i
mean that junior year like i talked
about this summer i listened to
financial peace university on cd driving
200.
yeah yeah driving to him from work and
then um
i read entre leadership i read total
money makeover i read financial peace
university like the book form too
um and
then i i think i started watching on on
youtube like i mean now now i just binge
watch it all the time so wow that's what
i did while i was paying off 39 000 in a
year is pretty impressive yeah yeah
how did you almost
almost tripled your salary yeah so
um kovid actually was a little bit of a
blessing for me because i was needed at
work and they started doing bonuses um
when i like sometimes when you picked up
it was like already extra incentive and
you would work more and then you get
more incentive and
and then i started about i was but i was
killing myself like there was
times when i was just like so exhausted
and i got covered in july because i was
just working all the time and my immune
system was like we don't like this this
is not good too but um i
um i started travel nursing
yeah
yeah so that helped make money yeah
bigger shovel for sure
yeah and i'd always i'd always wanted to
do it but it just happened to be like a
really good time and i thought again
kind of popped in my head i was like i'm
gonna do this i'm just gonna do it now
your parents are hovering around in your
memory david's kind of pushing this
forward from the fiance perspective yeah
and you look down went okay i'm doing it
yeah yeah it was it's kind of i'm kind
of one of those people like it has to be
my idea yeah to do it but yeah
your fiance's nodding yes
yeah i can just see her walking out her
front yard being like i declared
her neighbors are i think she's lost it
yeah exactly yeah
congratulations thank you
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt you know there's a
couple that i have in in the back of my
head i think that having a vision for
how you're how you want your life to be
you know i think that's huge it's you
know the debt snowball is only one baby
step it's baby step number two you know
there's how many other baby steps you
know and so you have to think big
picture like where i want my life to be
and then you have to make that committed
decision to stick with a plan and just
go for it day after day you you commit
and you recommit
give yourself grace when you mess up
because it's going to happen
um and you know maybe you take five
dollars out of your fun money and just
go buy yourself a coffee sit yourself
down be like i can do this okay we can
do this and then keep going you know it
sounds like that happened yeah
there were times when i was just like
so tired i didn't want to go to work and
i was just like you know i get gung-ho
about
picking up a shift or something and then
you know a week later i have to work it
and they actually need me and i'm like
oh man i really just don't want to go oh
i'm glad you mentioned that because we
talk a lot about like i just i just
sucked it up and grinded it out and i
got a third job and then also in a year
later it was over
there are a lot of those mornings that
you're like i signed up for what i know
like i just worked all day yesterday and
you're like yeah my eyes are crashing
on schedule and i gotta have a cup of
coffee and go i'm gonna go right back
into it there's a lot of nights when
well night stays i don't even know i
worked anything and everything that was
open i picked up shifts like i'm i work
ob like
babies and pregnant people are my thing
like i was doing some icu shifts and med
surg shifts and i'm like i don't like
taking care of adults that don't have a
baby in them so
you know i was like i'm gonna do this so
yeah
yeah but yes it is it is a grind and you
just gotta like drink your coffee and
probably some water too because you
might be a little low on that and just
keep keep going and it also helps to
have a supportive person in your life
you know if it's cheering you on oh my
gosh every time they text me be like hey
like we need help and you know he and i
were just even gonna hang out at home he
was like yeah babe go get it go go make
that money you know so he was very
supportive and um but yeah i just i
think that it's um understanding that
it's the other thing is it's just for a
season
exactly 13 whole months out of your
entire life yeah and i mean we just i
changed my family too you know i i mean
now you work whenever you want
where are you
only when you want yeah you don't have
any payments no you work like no one
else later you can work like no one else
you know it's like no i don't think so
yeah and you can give like no one else
to like i mean now it's still smaller
skill than i want it to be but i have
all these dreams of you know creating
scholarships for people and helping
people get through their education and
just you know i love animals so i want
to help that too
so well congratulations we're very proud
of you thank you so have you all set a
date
yes august 13th here we go yes all right
game on we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter for you and david after august
13th that's pretty cool another copy of
total money makeover you can give it
away and uh be part of somebody someone
else's story stirring up a ruckus so
good stuff john and i the whole ramsay
team we're proud of you very well done
ali from minnesota 59 000 in 13 months
making 58 all the way to 120 kicking it
count it down let's hear a glittery
debt-free scream three two one i'm dead
[Applause]
that's how they do it in minnesota i'm
just saying
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
crazy how time flies the pre-order of dr
john deloney's new book on your past
change your future is ending today
here's why you would pre-order today you
only buy the book for 20 but you get the
book and the ebook for free and you get
free weekly therapy sessions from better
help for one month you don't want to
miss out on this it's a great great
bargain
this book own your past change your
future the not so complicated approach
to relationships mental health and
wellness
absolutely incredible hey john's going
on the road going to do a couple of book
signings this thursday he'll be in
phoenix april the 21st at 6 p.m at the
barnes and noble at desert ridge
marketplace on tatum boulevard and then
next week a week from wednesday in
dallas texas at the barnes noble in
prestonwood town center on beltline road
wednesday april the 27th at 6 pm if
you're in dallas or phoenix mark those
down you can find the dates and
locations and everything on our website
as well and be sure you come in if you
ever wanted dr john doloni sit down with
you face to face and walk you through
what's happened with you
maybe you're healing from a traumatic
experience maybe you have had things in
your past maybe you're just dealing with
anxiety from covet whatever it is you're
dealing with
everyone has dealt with something or is
dealing with something right now this is
his um his method of sitting down with
you because he logistically can't be
everywhere it was and it's through this
book it will change your life the people
inside this building that have read the
book the advanced readers that have read
the book are all
going crazy about it because it just
grabs you and it gives you a framework
for
dealing with and thinking about the past
owning your past so you can change your
future alyssa is with us alyssa is in
green bay wisconsin hi alyssa welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
calls sure what's up
so the reason i'm calling um is because
last week i had a miscarriage
um i'm so sorry
thank you um
and
where
the question i had was i
my husband and i are in baby steps four
five and six so when we found out we
were pregnant we kind of paused on the
extra chunks we normally throw at our
mortgage and we put it in a separate
account um to just kind of keep it there
as we go through pregnancy and now that
i'm no longer pregnant i looked over at
that and i thought oh i should throw
that at the mortgage um no but then
there was also a part of me that was
like
i want to do something with that i want
to go somewhere and i guess my question
is do we
what's the difference between
you know being in a place that we can
take the time away and do something for
ourselves versus um grief spending or
being irresponsible in some way
it fits the framework of what we teach
so i'm not going to call where they're
responsible
all right now that what we teach is is
you're not in if you're in baby step two
i'd have to kind of [ __ ] my head and cry
with you a minute and think about with
this pain what we're gonna do but you're
you're past baby step three and that's
where you do things that's where you buy
a couch that's where you go on a trip
that's where you upgrade the car with
cash that you have in your case you were
using it had it labeled for one thing
you want to change the label of it to
trip
uh to get away
um
and so i
it's not financially irresponsible
the question is you know that then do
you want to
you know you want to make sure you're
doing this from a healthy perspective in
terms of processing the grief yeah so
right here's what i would tell you
alyssa this would be important this trip
is important and i think you for sure
should take a trip
i would put a little bit of money aside
to give away there's something about
giving that is healing in these moments
and this is going to be hard i'm going
to say this really abruptly because we
just have a short time together um if
you and i were sitting down talking 101
i would probably be a little more
eloquent in my speech okay
this trip in and of itself won't heal
your hurt
what this trip can do is provide a
little bit of space
for you and your husband to sit down and
just
be sad together because y'all had plans
right and
you've had a loss and so the trip in and
of itself won't be the gift the the the
trip will provide space for you all to
then begin healing i strongly strongly
strongly i've been down this road
multiple times in my own home
strongly recommend some sort of
um even if it's just you two some sort
of funeral some sort of remembrance some
sort of
marker for this moment
and it'll be a touchstone for you and
your husband as y'all both move into the
future right into what comes next um but
yeah i say go on the trip leave a little
money for giving though that's important
yeah have some spa days and there's
nothing is
uh
uh
but but i'm with john you you know this
but we're just saying out loud kind of
what you were thinking okay
the trip is good do the trip but there's
no place on earth beautiful enough or
peaceful enough to make you not hurt
you're hurting
yeah
okay and thank you i really appreciate
it yeah be okay with that in other words
the trip is not an elixir
that allows you to sidestep the grief
and the hurt and the pain and alyssa let
me tell you this
this hurts i miss this big time um
in my own home and so i'll i carry that
i'll carry that first of my life
there is a um an entire
ecosystem that is designed to tell you
well this isn't that big of a well it
should have been and people are going to
give you their terrible advice and their
stuff that you can sew on a pillow and
all that kind of stuff
you need to spend some time with people
who will just sit with you and aren't
going to throw advice at you are going
to give you a bunch of labels aren't
going to give you a bunch of nonsense
and you need to know that you're hurt
right now and your pain and your loss is
valid and it's real and it's holy and
i'm s as your friend i'm so sorry that
this happened to you amen
thank you okay thank you i appreciate it
yeah you betcha
you know take the trip but don't turn
the trip into something it's not don't
give it that kind of power
right right yeah thank you and just it's
a and and you know we want to give you
permission to hurt we're hurting with
you yeah and just um
yeah but y'all just sit you know
somewhere on the beach or wherever
you're going and cry a little bit
that'll be okay
okay thank you so much yeah you bet god
bless you darling i'm sorry you're going
through this
hey and i appreciate you saying that
dave because there's um
when she asked that question i thought
i've been here for a few years and i've
never heard that question asked and i i
i well she's a baby step four yeah i
love that your default was again if
she's on two i gotta i gotta think about
well y'all still running for your lives
yeah you know you got two different
things coming at you now that's right
you got this overwhelming debt you're
trying to get out of with intensity and
how well how are we gonna get but the
trip the purpose of the trip here i'm
not putting words in your mouth but in
my mind it's get give yourself
some space
to grieve and you can create space to
grieve without spending a lot of money
if you were in baby step two absolutely
you can't it's just there's something
powerful about the change in this case
in this case she's got the money to
create some luxurious space grief and
that's okay yeah it's okay to spend it
on that one of the things when uh we're
writing this book we're talking about
the our culture that we have about
loss and and people that we love passing
and it hit me while i remember where i
was when i was typing these out
if you're if you are in debt
if you're running for your life and you
own six figures of student loans
and you work hourly
you have to do a cost-benefit analysis
on how much can i even attend this
funeral
and i thought how much more important is
living a life without debt because it
gives you space to actually live your
life and i think i've always thought of
living your life as going on vacation is
doing the thing paying for college
but what if i just need a week to
process when my mom passes away what if
i need to get buy a plane ticket tonight
to go be with my uncle before he passes
away
these are all things that i didn't
consider when i was six figures in
student loan debt right and it just
provides you a space and some margin
just to breathe when life comes at you
money is not important at all what money
does yeah is unbelievably important yeah
feed your children
gives you a plane ticket to go see your
uncle yeah gives you a little space in
her case to
uh have a a luxurious uh
which is fine uh mart time of margin
yeah uh it gives you that it gives you
the it turns a crisis into an
inconvenience now not in a not in her
situation it's not an i'm not saying a
miscarriage is inconvenienced no i'll
tell you this i've sat with people in
the middle of the night that say i can't
i don't know how to pay for a coffin
yeah i don't know what's i don't know
what's next here but it turns it turns
the
the
it it no matter what the drama is being
broke adds layers to the drama big time
that's right and we've all we all run
into hurt on top
yeah you know
i drove my four winner on a ditch this
weekend broke the front broke the front
axle off the thing so is that a problem
no i'll just get another one yeah you
know yeah i didn't bump my head too hard
you know but the uh uh but that's but
but you know if in the old days my buddy
and i were laughing about it and we're
like in the old days this would have
been the next two weeks of our life
dealing with this stupid thing now i
just left it there and said get somebody
come get it fix it good lord
you know so it just adds drama to the
drama dr john dolone's new book own your
past change your future get it on
pre-order while you can
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print a
ramsey network production
of a podcast that is absolutely blowing
it out of the water in popularity be
sure you check it out he's my co-host
today thank you for joining us we're so
glad you're here
this is a show about your relationships
it's a show about building wealth it's a
show about getting work that you
love making more money than you've ever
made in your life we're glad you're here
thank you for joining us triple eight
eight two five five two two five jason
is with us in raleigh north carolina hi
jason welcome to the ramsey show
thank you so much for taking my call
dave sure man what's up
hey me and my wife are looking for some
guidance we're both 26 years old we've
been married for a year renting an
apartment for a year as well
our lease is up at the end of may and
the cost of living is going to make our
rent go up by at least three hundred and
fifty dollars a month
um since we were going to be paying that
much for
rent we looked into churchill mortgage
to
start looking for the process of buying
a home
since we had no debt we have never had a
credit card we have a zero we don't have
a zero credit score but we have a no
credit score at all so they said it was
gonna make our rate go up quite a bit um
for a pre-approval it's going to be
about 6.8 percent of what they gave us
which is seems pretty high even for the
market right now you got to hold on bad
information and i'm gonna have to get
you offline and get you back with
churchill because uh whoever you got a
hold of there's an idiot
okay george you didn't pay a dime more
you got a no credit score
mortgage from churchill mortgage and you
were not charged a premium on the
interest rate we actually i asked about
this on the fine print podcast we
interviewed one of their specialists
over to churchill on the fine print
podcast on credit scores and he
explained to me that they basically rate
you at a good credit score if you do
manual underwriting and everything
checks out they're ready i said how does
this compare to someone who has a credit
score and they said we look at it we say
this is rated as good so it's not the
highest credit score if you had an eight
hundred you might get certainly eight
percent no that's not this market in
this three percent world's not even
close to true something else is wrong or
you got to hold a bad uh rep one of the
two so have you got uh you have no
credit at all of any kind no bad credit
showing up
no sir not at all how long have you been
on your
uh job years and how long have you paid
rent
for just one year
okay that none of that warrants a six
point eight percent rate
so uh yeah that's kind of what we
help you with that a were
bit apparently you got like a newbie or
something that doesn't know what the
flip they're doing but um you may have
just typed in the computer and spit out
our numbers yeah kelly kelly i'll uh get
you in touch with the owners of
churchill and we'll get this fixed for
you because it's just not right i mean
it's not it's not how it works manual
underwriting is not a double interest
rate it should be a uh you know as good
an interest rate as a person can get
with a typical credit score is what you
were told and that's what you personally
got yeah and if you had an excellent
credit score you might get a slightly
lower rate like an eighth or a quarter
exactly but we're not talking two
percent my rate was probably right there
if not maybe a point one percent
difference than someone who had a great
credit score so well exactly and i you
know the goal here is you pay it off as
fast as possible and if that if the 0.1
or 0.2 percent interest rate jump is
going to make you not able to afford the
house you may just not be ready to buy a
house yeah but this is but
these numbers 6.8 is not right no that's
just wrong so you hold on kelly will
pick up and we'll get you in touch with
our internal team at ramsey trusted and
they'll walk you through the churchill
mortgage process and sorry you got some
bad info there but that's very fixable
very very doable john is with us john is
in boston hey john welcome to the ramsey
show
hello dave
i am calling in because i have about 13
842 dollars worth of
uh car payment loans uh i only have one
car
and i drive about an hour and a half
every day to work
with the price of get
uh there's i'm a jeweler and there's no
real jeweler positions in my area
um move so
yeah i've i've been thinking about
either i've found you guys about a week
and a half ago
i'm deciding whether i should find
something new closer to home
or selling my car and driving a beater
just trying to get advice on what to do
so what's the purpose of selling the car
um
i
probably buy something cheaper uh that i
wouldn't have to you know owe any debt
on
um
yeah i
i like that part i'm just wondering the
connection between you getting a job and
this car being
sold
um
an hour and a half a day yeah yeah yeah
that's true more money and just more
time i guess
um because i'm spending about 800 a
month on gas and the car payment is like
300 so it's over a thousand just
just to get to work uh so i'm basically
not making much money right
okay
so uh
it it sounds like you got three things
you need to rethink where you live what
you drive and what you do for a living
and rethinking all three of those should
completely change your whole life
yes
okay now i get rid of the car payment i
mean 13 000 i mean what are you making a
year what do you make of here
uh it's about 30 32 grand
okay
how old are you
i'm 23.
okay
all right and what are you going to be
doing when you're 33 that makes a
hundred thousand
i honestly have no idea dave okay
all right so i don't mind you making 30.
i don't mind you making 32 because i've
made 32. but i want to be going
somewhere from there i don't want to be
staying there
yeah
so let's have a game plan on your career
side
so what i'll do is i'll send you a copy
of ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose to start making your decisions
on your career
[Music]
from a quality of life standpoint i get
to decide what i'm going to spend two
things on that are very valuable to me
my time and my money
and commutes
are
destroyed both of those
and so you really have to decide from a
qual you know where do you want to end
up 40 years from today
a two-hour commute is gonna destroy your
money and destroy your time just four
hours a day
and so and these are two things that are
too valuable that you can get you can't
get back the time you can get back the
money
but um but you know i'm moving or i'm
changing jobs
and i'm going to get you know continue
to do something to change jobs anyway to
move from 32 on up and out of that yeah
you're gonna have to uproot your life
man new car new job new life new
everything but man that commute it's
wearing you out and wearing your car out
both are not good yeah it's um i don't i
don't know did you have to quit any of
it today
but six months from now i probably would
have a new car
a new job
and a new place to live
or at least two of those three that'd be
a win at least two of those three to
start to get my life back
thank you man we appreciate you being a
listener this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well george
rachel cruz and i john deloney ken
coleman and i are really excited ramsey
solutions is hitting the road we're
pumped to take our building wealth live
event on tour this year
look out las vegas and orlando we're
coming to you in just a couple of weeks
and then this fall sacramento
minneapolis
san antonio and another city yet to be
announced las vegas is may the 5th
that's only a couple weeks away and you
can still get tickets if you want them
they're almost sold out orlando getting
very close to being sold out may 19th
and we just put sacramento minneapolis
and san antonio on sale and we've
already sold over a thousand tickets to
each one of those thank you so much
tickets are only 25 dollars one of the
reasons they're selling so fast and a
four pack is 60
so bring a couple friends with you it's
only less than the cost of a pizza come
on out we're gonna spend an evening
together we'll sign books
answer questions we're going to do
an event about building wealth again
vegas is may 5 orlando's may 19th
sacramento november 1. minneapolis
november 10 san antonio november 15
ramseysolutions.com
events george i'm ready to be back on
the road bro oh and these are some great
cities i'm just thinking about all the
crowds we've seen in these kinds of
cities and at that price point i mean
it's inflation-proof yeah it's the only
thing that has not suffered from
inflation is uh tickets to building
wealth you know what
that's true we didn't double them did we
no
we should we should thank you welcome
america well and we gotta pay the gas
bill if we're gonna drive over there
that's true so how we gonna do that if
we don't get more money i haven't
thought about this i thought you were
the guy to figure all this out hmm
well i never thought about raising the
prices just call it generosity okay
we'll call it that that's part of
building well it's gonna be a great time
our question of the day is from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
you pick the wrong color they're going
to remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping new promos all the
time incredible company for window
coverings and blinds for your home
blinds.com always use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from kevin in utah i
start a new job next week and instead of
a 401k match they contribute 12 to 15 of
my base salary each year
should i still put 15 percent in the
company's roth 401k or should i just put
the 15 in my roth ira they contribute
regardless of whether i use the 401k or
not
interesting what are they contributing
to
contribute of my base salary each year
he says i'm guessing he means to the 401
whether he puts money in the 401k
i guess they're putting it in the 401k
regardless of whether he puts it in oh
it's coming out of his paycheck it
sounds like no no
they are contributing but i'm just
saying
they contribute regardless of whether i
use the 401k or not i assume i mean he
has to be in the 401k yeah so okay well
yes you need to put 15
of your money you put 15 of your money
in regardless of what your company does
although this is an absolute fabulous
benefit i know i'm just shocked at this
they're just giving them 15 for nothing
there well as far as your options go he
said should i put in the 401k or the ira
you're talking about roth in either case
and so i like the 401k option it's
simple your money's already going there
if you want to do the roth ira there are
some different benefits to that you may
have more investment options
so that's a good place to do it now the
roth ira you're going to max out pretty
quickly there so you're probably going
to have to go back to the roth 401k
anyways
should i still put 15 percent of the
company's roth 401k or should i put the
15 of my in my roth ira it doesn't
matter
which one because neither one have a
match you're getting them you're getting
the money the contribution regardless of
the match i would just go where you
think you've got the best options if
your 401k has
good solid options across the four types
of mutual funds we're talking about i
would just do your 401k for convenience
but if you put 15 percent of your income
into
a roth ira and that's not maxed out
because you're in if you have a higher
income it would max out
um
again you pick those four types of
mutual funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and
international good question sarah is
with us in los angeles hi sarah welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you so much dave we love you and
your team so thank you for all the
advice that you're giving me love that
you're inspiring the youth especially to
live responsibly well thank you how can
we help today
well
i have two questions we have uh real
estate investments that we've had for a
long time we have five homes
in the sunbelt area arizona and
florida
with probably a total of
a 1.2 million combined
and we're getting about 10 to 15 000 a
year
free and clear from that
so it's not a really great
investment from a cash flow standpoint
and we've been looking into dst's i
wanted to see what you thought of them
you have a million dollars where the
real estate is creating 10 000 worth of
cash flow
yeah
you have
mortgages no
so that that's what is wrong with the
real estate
or are you guys just the worst landlords
on the planet
they're all they're all uh financially
or professionally managed so no they're
not
you would have sold them are you
charging like 300 for rent how is this
possible
well actually last year was more like 20
000. so it is getting better but still
twenty thousand over five homes
yeah you should be getting that's four
grand a year a month
yeah so what would happen is we'll get
something where summer moves out and we
have like
8 000 repairs one of them needs a 12 000
roof
so something like that will just sync us
for the year
but not on all five
no not on all five you're saying twenty
thousand dollars a piece or twenty
thousand dollars total on a million
dollars worth of real estate
2000 total okay these properties are not
renting well
i mean i i own a lot of real estate okay
and um
i'm making an eight to a ten percent
cash on cash after repairs and after
tenant turnover on residential single
families
much of these are residential single
families ten percent on a million two be
a hundred and twenty thousand a year
eight percent would be a hundred
thousand a year
so you know you're you're way off here
something's wrong are these properties
not desirable are they bad why are they
bad rental properties are they super
expensive property or what's the are
they cheap or what i mean
well the one in arizona is worth over
300 the ones whose border are worth
around 250 each
so
what's wrong with 1500
one needs a roof
um that's where we were
that's where we were looking into dst
because we thought maybe we could get
better cash flow
well you could get better cash flow if
you manage the real estate well or you
had better cash flow than you'll ever
get on an eft
real estate will outperform mutual funds
and efts it has a higher hassle factor
if it is runway this real estate is not
being run well i think you've got some
property managers milking you
i'd pay attention to these numbers and
really dig into this and figure out
where all this money i'm telling you i
can i take a million dollars worth of
single families and put them up beside
you and i'm making a hundred grand 120
grand on it
cash flow
cash on cash
and
by the way rents have gone up
rents have gone up so that's why we're
making more like the one in arizona now
we get
1700 a month
but in florida they're still relatively
low
and the taxes are really high
and insurance is high too in florida
so we bought most of them for about a
hundred thousand
and so they've appreciated a lot so our
total outlay is not
a million it's more like yeah if i know
it's not your outlay but it's return on
value is what it amounts to and a
general rule of thumb is you should see
a gross rent before expenses
not net but before expenses of around
one percent a month so 300 thousand
dollar house that'll be three three
thousand bucks a month rent
give or take okay and that's gonna net
you that's a 12
gross and then that's going to net you
10
to 8 to 10 depending on your level of
repairs and so forth and i think you're
not getting good value out of your
property manager or these properties are
very poorly located
if you want to sell them and get into an
eft you can out you can beat what you're
doing with an eft but as a category
single families manage well will
outperform an eft if they're done right
and these are not being done right
there's something wrong with this
portfolio
thanks for the call
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage glenn
and wendy are with us hey guys how are
you hey doing great welcome where do you
guys live we live in morris alabama
which is near a little north of
birmingham birmingham all right cool how
much debt have you guys paid off we paid
off a hundred grand all right how long
did this take you uh 22 months good for
you and your range of income during that
130 to 138 130 138 what do you guys do
for a living i'm a wastewater treatment
plant operator
and i'm an occupational therapist for
the local school system excellent very
cool what kind of debt was the hundred
thousand uh 3 500 was a 401k loan that
i'd taken out and then the rest of it
was the remainder of her mortgage you
paid off your home yeah look at the
weird people
yeah i love it what's this house worth
my wife was gonna be so mad if you
didn't call us weird today you're aware
yeah you are officially weird yeah don't
be mad yeah
how what's the house worth uh
gordonzilla pushing 300. okay excellent
good job you guys good job how long have
you all been married uh 26 years oh cool
how old are you i'm 47. and i'm 48. all
right good and i paid for a house yes
sir wow
that's record-breaking man that's very
very cool very exciting very cool
congratulations so what put you on this
journey 22 months ago tell us about your
story um i
i listened i started listening to you
back in the 90s i guess i've known about
dave ramsey forever and loved the show
and we were ish our whole life i guess
our whole married life anyway
but 22 months ago i changed jobs and
we had to do something about that for
one kayla on that i'd take it down and
we knocked it out very quickly
and uh
we kept thinking well if we we could do
this we could just
take that mortgage out very quickly and
our goal was to do it by the time wendy
turned 50
but we we were able to knock it out even
a little quicker wow and in 2018 i have
two of my co-workers jennifer nick and
ashley dees who are my debt-free
cheerleaders
we walk after school every wednesday our
walk-in wednesdays and one of the things
we talk about is our financial goals our
financial dreams and so i'm the first of
the three to get to come do this
and they're on their way all right look
forward to all of them i love it all
debt-free houses and everything
excellent job guys
very very very well done awesome you get
some people around you and you feel a
little bit of that progress you get a
taste and you go okay we paid off three
let's pay off 97. let's go
yeah was that scary when you were just
looking at that number going how are we
going to do this
yes it was from so we started our
debt-free journey january of 2020 right
before the pandemic hit and from january
to may we were making some progress but
it it wasn't until we started doing the
every dollar budget that we really
started to
to see that progress
come to fruition and at the end of every
month no matter how many dollars or
cents were left at the end of each
category we added all that up and threw
it at the mortgage we called it our our
fun math at the end of each month yeah i
love it well done guys great job
man that's a 300 000 paid for
house so how much do you guys have in
your investments in your retirement uh
we're a little over two hundred okay in
that area all right half a million yes
sir net worth excellent you're gonna be
millionaires before you know it yeah
that's what we're looking for good for
good job you guys very cool all right so
every dollar is part of the key what
other keys do you tell people it is to
having your house paid off i just think
the fact that we were we were just on
the same page the whole time um was was
tremendous uh and getting it knocked out
we we hardly ever there was no argument
just like we knew what we needed to do
and we got the job done
was there fights at all or just with
money i'm just curious there weren't
and that's one thing that i wanted to be
sure and say is how god united us so
completely during this journey last
night we were talking about that very
question and neither one of us could
think of a single time
that i wanted to do something that
wasn't in the budget or he wanted to do
something that wasn't in the budget
and i just feel like god
honors financial responsibility and he
has been with us
through the whole journey
22 months of focus and boom you're done
yeah and you're not even 50 years old
right just like that wow so how's it
feel to not have a payment in the world
oh that's wonderful i was telling wendy
that this is the most carefree i've been
since i was a kid it's it's amazing to
this feeling you have just with the the
peace and the freedom
of being debt-free wow what was it was
it momentous with the last payment how
did you guys do it
so it was october 29th this past october
and we went to a little restaurant out
in bessemer the bright star restaurant
had our picture made in front of it and
it was just such a
such a happy day and the other thing to
mention too is our son
is a college student at uab
and um we were um
cash flowing cash flowing his college
his college at the same time wow wow we
had some car repairs we've got all old
cars now so that's our next thing is to
yeah we're going to step into our real
dave car next time
yeah i like it i like it that's fun well
congratulations you guys absolutely
amazing very very very well done
okay
doesn't sound like this was super hard
once the two of you decided you just
went after it it really wasn't and one
of our biggest things that we struggle
with is eating out oh yeah that was
that's how to eat and so what we did in
our budget is we allowed ourselves one
out to eat a week
on grocery night and it was usually fast
food yeah and that would fill us up
before we went and bought groceries so
it kept the grocery bill down
don't go in there hungry yeah exactly
well you're in baby steps four five six
at that point that's perfectly allowed
now if you're in baby step two i'll fuss
at you for going but you guys are just
working that working that baby step six
get rid of that mortgage and you knocked
it out way to go thank you very proud of
you guys you're heroes man
yeah man you did it you're just weird
excellent job all right glenn and wendy
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can too
number one best seller and that's the
next chapter in your story also a copy
total money makeover you can give it
away to somebody stir up a ruckus get
them started on this tell them what you
did and um it's not bragging because you
did it and i'm proud of you very very
well done ramsey's proud of you george
is proud of you well done you guys glenn
and wendy birmingham alabama 100 000
paid off in 22 months
making 130 to 138 house and everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
we're dead free
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh man oh man
it's just a matter of intentionality
once you decide
i'm going to be intentional i'm going to
make every one of these dollars behave
i'm not going to live like this i want
to be free once you decide then you'll
start adjusting things in your life to
get there
and you know what was their big
sacrifice they only ate out once a
week ooh
i thought
i don't know how they're gonna make it i
mean that was incredible they didn't i
mean they just walk up my point is is
they didn't have to really strain they
had to be intentional yeah and there
wasn't like some kind of hold your
breath and be underwater for two hours
you know there wasn't anything like that
this was just i'm gonna do it on purpose
and once you start doing it on purpose
the level of traction is incredible oh
yeah looking back 22 months is like a
snap yep and you're done but when you're
looking forward you go man two years i
don't know if i can do it when you look
back you go man that was a blip in our
life and now we're free forever
that's a different mindset 24 months ago
we had this thing called covet
i mean it was everywhere we were all
shut down 24 months ago right now the
whole place was shut down right it feels
like yesterday and a decade ago at the
same time yeah i'm going with the decade
parts one i'm sticking with oh my gosh
you know and uh but i mean you know it's
how fast it goes yeah that feels like 20
seconds ago in a way right
uh in another way it feels like a decade
ago so you sacrifice for 22 months you
won't have a mortgage payment for the
next 22 years it's amazing how that
works isn't that neat if you're willing
to do what it takes if you live like no
one else later you get to live and give
like no one else no discipline seems
pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host i'm dave ramsey your host this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 825-5225
sophia is in salt lake city utah hi
sophia welcome to the ramsay show
thank you
what's up
my question for you today is my husband
and i are just about ready to complete
baby step number two
and we decided to relocate once we
complete baby step 3.
my question today is
do we purchase a home where we plan on
relocating and keeping the home we are
in so we would have two mortgages
and then try to sell this one
or do we go and relocate and rent while
we sell this home or do we just sell
this home
and then purchase another one
we're wanting to save up 20
before we buy a new home
for a down payment
okay good i mean i like option three
where you just sell it and relocate
what's holding you back from doing that
um
just that we
we weren't quite sure we don't we won't
have the 20 percent
right you don't have enough equity in
your current home
we do um we're just kind of there's not
a whole lot of homes on the market where
we're relocating so
we figured that if we just
rented that it would help us save the 20
per down and then we could find the home
that we really want so sell the house
the current home that you own does not
have any equity
oh it it does it has about 150 000
equity okay and how expensive a home
would you buy when you relocate
um right now the homes are going for
about 400 000 over there okay that would
be 25 then so you'd be just fine right
so
put your home on the market and sell it
and then go over there and buy a house
okay with that money perfect
that's option c right there's nothing
wrong with renting at the new spot for a
while and figuring out what the lay of
the land is and where you want to live
and all that stuff so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to get in touch with a
ram go to ramseysolutions.com get in
touch with the ramsey elp
get your house on the market
and uh is there a job change and
everything involved
yes so i can actually um change my job
right now he would need to stay for six
to eight months
um
but
he
i guess we're just kind of waiting until
we have baby step three it would make us
feel more secure yeah that's fine no
problem with that before we leave so but
i mean the point is in terms of the real
estate transaction once you have the
jobs lined up and the other logistics
other than the real estate
uh and you're ready to go okay ready set
go whatever that means to you okay put
that house on the market it will sell
very quickly in this current environment
agreed
you agree then you just take that
contract in your hand it's going to
close in 30 days probably and you go to
the other place and you start looking
for houses and you buy one to close
around the same time that yours is going
to close
if you can't find one in the new place
because there's nothing available or you
can't find a decent deal or anything
like that well then just rent but that's
your renting is your worst case scenario
but selling the current property and you
know within the period of time that it's
set up to close buy another one and
close on it simultaneously
or within days you'd have to close on
your first one you're the one you're
selling first because you got the money
to buy the second one right
i mean if you close on a two if you
close on yours on a tuesday and the one
you're buying on a wednesday and they um
you know and you load up the truck and
you head to beverly
okay
would you ever suggest that we move
before baby step three is completed
maybe okay it's not the end of the world
okay because you're gonna have a hundred
thousand dollars in your pocket
correct when you move so you're not
gonna be broke
um okay you know so it's okay if you
don't have it completed or if you only
had three months or something if it
makes you feel better to have that but
my point is if you cannot then set up a
simultaneous transaction like i'm
discussing
meaning you can't find something that
you can close on or move into
or you you know you move into a rental
for two months while you get this all
figured out
but you don't necessarily have to rent
for two years in the new location you
know if you just the trick is just to
get the logistics lined up of the two
deals
and so
you know that's what we're looking at
so i did a similar thing this year my
last year myself sophia we sold our we
had this big old huge house up on a hill
that we loved then we lived in for
almost 15 years and while the market was
hot we decided we're getting out of that
and um
so
we bought a lot to build on that we'll
build on some day and uh we sold that
big house and so we were homeless
and um
ran out and bought a house in the same
neighborhood as the lot
to camp in for a while
using the money from the sale of the
first house that's called glamping dave
yeah it's not it's not it's not it's not
camping it's glamping you're right there
we go pretty luxurious accuracy pretty
luxurious camping site but yeah but the
uh point being that that we just had to
work out the logistics right we had to
figure out okay and i didn't need to
close on the new house that we're
glamping in
until the first one closed and so we had
to set up the closing to be after that i
had the money to buy both but i didn't
want the other one unless the big one
sold
closed not just sold i want the money in
my hand that's right and then we're
gonna go make the other deal
and we closed them the same week wow and
uh and then made had the moves arranged
the possession arranged around where we
had a little bit of time to make the
move without falling in on ourselves so
it's just a matter of negotiating and
finding something where the logistics
line up and work and then you're going
to be just fine so good question ross is
with us in bowling green kentucky hey
ross what's up
how's it going dave um
i am trying to decide if i want to pick
up an extra job to help pay for college
or summer why not
um well i'm already working one job and
plus i'll be doing a emt course so i get
my basic emt so i can try and start
do firefighting which i'm still trying
to get my probationary books signed off
on that so i just i want a college and
emt
yes why which one are you going to do
i'm well i was going to college first
and i was originally just going to get
my bachelor's because i was going to go
into law enforcement but my stepdad
who's a state trooper talked me out of
that
so i looked into firefighting so why are
you still going to college
uh
because at this point it's like i feel
like i'm halfway through and i feel like
i'd be a waste of money if i wouldn't
finish it out and get something from it
okay so you can't cash flow college if
you don't pick up this additional job
you're gonna have to go into debt i
i i don't know because it's tuition's
about twelve thousand and i'm not gonna
be living on campus anymore i've got
past the two years that i had to live on
campus
and i feel like i could get enough money
but it's just now i'll have an apartment
and i just i guess i'm a little worried
because i know i'm not gonna be able to
work as much during what i have classes
well the focus right now is getting
through your courses getting through
your emt program and doing it all
debt-free so whatever that takes i'm
doing it
yeah okay priority number one emt school
priority number two finish college
priority number three way the flip down
the list is an apartment
are you in town with your parents
uh no okay then get the cheapest
freaking possible thing you can don't be
working for an apartment
be working to do the other two goals
you got roommates ross
yeah i'll have a roommate how much more
expensive is the apartment than on
campus
um the apartment's less money than on
campus living
okay so you should be able to with your
current expenses cover that right
i i should be able to yeah
okay well uh when in doubt i'm working
you're you're what 22 23 years old
uh 20. 20 years old yeah
you're not gonna die from working
so when in doubt i'm gonna work more
make some money
because a big old pile of money solves a
whole lot of god's problems right here
you know what i'm saying
and you know
getting up to the edge and then going ah
man i'm i'm 500 bucks off
500 dollars off in your world's a lot
off
you won't be 500 off so i'm gonna have
the extra money extra pile of money that
big old pile of money gives you peace
that you get to hit all your goals which
is finish school and emt school go
download every dollar get your every
dollar budget going start doing some
math and look at reality yeah you need
to map out what your expenses are going
to be on the emt school on your tuition
and on the apartment and go this is how
much money i need plus some
and if that means you're working extra
have at it brother
no one most of us worked when we were in
school none of us died from it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this is the ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five gene starts off this hour
in cincinnati ohio hi gene welcome to
the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
so um
and you should also say you help people
clean up messes because i have one um
so
my ex-husband and i um 16 years ago
bought a house in our name
for my son and his wife and their three
children we he's our only child
and um we did that because
their credit was not good at the time
and
they were busting up themes in one room
one bedroom i should say and so
um the agreement was they were to clean
up their credit and get the house out of
our name in five years
that was 16 years ago that was 16 years
ago and
and my husband and i were married at the
time we found my ex-husband um so that's
problem one
um
problem two um is
that skip forward um they now have four
kids
um where i'm remarried he's remarried
and um
he is 70 and i'm mid-60s he is not in
the best of health
and
i have my health issues and so
um my
son and daughter-in-law mentioned
the other day that they were concerned i
didn't i didn't know that my ex-husband
had health issues but
they mentioned the other day that he
does and they're concerned
this was their concern that if something
happened um the ex-wife has several
children what would happen if the house
was still in his name yeah so maybe they
ought to do something about it after 16
months right but they still can't their
credit is still really bad
and um and then amount and of course the
market is as
good as it has ever been and so
um the house on paper has gone up
dramatically in value
um
this couldn't all this question couldn't
happen in a worse time but
so
the problem now is
getting out of there out of our names
and they don't have the credit where
they could go get a loan
um and i assume that you still owe on
the house
right and the other part of that
agreement was that they would make all
the house payments and we never uh
whatever the house payment was
they made it and we rolled everything in
together my husband and i have
ex-husband
had really good credit i still do i
don't know what my ex's
cert circumstances are so what are you
all gonna do
well that's what i'm calling for so
here's what my my husband and i
my current husband and i
um
were talking about um
so i could afford i could take it out of
my um retirement savings and just we owe
less than thirty thousand on it
um
the house probably is valued over a
hundred plus i don't really don't know
what it would be valued at but this
market
but um i could i could pay it off but
the question is
how do we transfer it to them without um
any gift checks um i don't know how to
do what is your net worth
my husband and i
um
probably a few million okay all right so
you want to give them another 30 000 and
just deed it to them
and you think your ex will deed it to
them
well that was the agreement to begin
with i know but willie if you do this
the agreement to begin with was they
paid off in five years it's been 16. so
nobody's done what they were supposed to
do yet in this whole deal absolutely
true but my my ex-husband and i you know
we've tried to do the right thing by
them
whether they did the right thing or not
yeah and um and again it kind of upset
me because her concern wasn't
you know oh he's in that health my
concern too is
he his financial picture isn't good if
he ended up needing nursing do you have
any contact with him at all
um limited okay
all right here's the thing
i don't have a problem with uh you
paying off 30 000
and right and signing the deed and you
can get in touch with your estate
planner
and file a unified estate tax credit
filing use up some
of your estate
exemption your federal estate exemption
to avoid gift tax so you can do this
without any harm to you and you're
giving them 30 000 bucks the whole thing
smells really bad because your son is a
complete parasite he's done a horrible
job of managing his life and honoring
his mother
but you're gonna do it anyway and so
this and this cleans it up and it's done
i would not do all of that
and then your ex not deed his half
well
let me ask you this because i tried to
do research and then i thought i could
just call dave ramsey isn't it would he
be able to do a quick claim deed to me
no he'll get a he'll get a gift tax as
well
he has to deed it to whoever you can
both quit claim it to your son
your half to your son
and but it doesn't avoid gift x unless
you file
a form
file called the unified estate
tax credit write that phrase down both
you and your ex are gonna do this
because you're giving him a gift that is
larger than fifteen thousand dollars and
you're gonna get taxed fifty five
percent on it if you do
without filing this form so you need to
talk to your cpa tax attorney estate tax
planner whoever's doing this stuff for
you
and it's it's not a hard thing to do but
it's very it's very easy but a one-page
quick one-page quit claim deed and a
unified estate tax credit by both you
and your ex and a 30 000 check to the
mortgage company and this deal's over
your son owns the house
quick claim deed
both of us
both of us need to file a unified
estate
tax credit
okay
and pay off the debt of thirty thousand
dollars
but if you give him your half
and your ex doesn't
and his
new wife ends up owning this with your
son
it would be just desserts but it'd be
another mess
okay i mean your son deserves a mess
because he is a mess
but there's no sense in creating one on
purpose so
i'd be in touch with your ex and try to
get this all coordinated like a little
concert move here
the paperwork is the simplest part of
this whole thing it's all the relational
and financial implications that worry me
16 years in the credit still in the tank
tells me he has not been managing money
well yeah and this is not going to be a
blessing to him but but it does clean it
up and for 30 grand and you got several
million in net worth it's
it's a clean transaction
but it's kind of one it's not kind of it
is one you got to hold your nose while
you do it
this is not really a blessing obviously
none of this has been a blessing to him
not gonna feel the whole freaking thing
was a bad idea
16 years ago
11 years ago when you didn't call him on
it
and now
it was a bad idea the whole thing's a
bad idea there's nothing in that's as
good no pretty girls at this party
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour open phones a triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
george the nicest
people
anywhere
are people who
psychologists like dr john deloney call
enablers
they are they cannot do they see someone
who says i need help with this and they
just want to be helpful
even though when you look at it the help
is actually not help
it's actually harm
and so when you give a drunk a drink
the drunk is very happy with you
but you're not really helping
you're enabling
assisting in
their misbehavior that brings harm to
them it doesn't harm you yeah so if you
participate in someone's crazy and
assist them in it
because you're sweet
and almost all enablers are very sweet
people and i'm not being sarcastic they
are very kind they're so kind that they
cannot do the
hard work of
conflict for someone else's good
see when you call in here we love you so
much
we're gonna bust you
for your own good
it doesn't change the cost of the call
it's free
either way
it it doesn't change that we love you it
doesn't change that we don't love you it
doesn't you know
and dave rams is tough no dave ramsey
loves you i want you to win so i'm going
to tell you the truth get out of the
street don't touch the hot stove you
know stay out stay away from these
things they bring you harm enablers on
the other hand participate our last
caller was an enabler
what i'm what i'm seeing here is
short-term help can lead to long-term
harm
that's what seems to be the pattern the
theme of all of these they're trying to
help in the short term because this
person can't do it on their own and
therefore we're going to give them a leg
up which is really going to hurt them
financially usually on this show in the
long term and usually relationally for
all parties involved long term so if
your kid has bad credit
they can't hold down a job
they're not going to get better by you
buying them a house
that simple hello
they're not it's not going to make their
life better now if you need to buy
groceries for your grandbabies to eat do
it
if you pay the light bill or something
occasionally that's up to you
but to the extent that you participate
in the mythology that they're not in
control of their life you are not being
a blessing to that point her son for 16
years
has never been able to recoup and put
his feet on the ground
after his mom and dad now divorced and
remarried both of them
bought him a house left it in both of
their names the house survived the
divorce
the homeownership survived the divorce
so they've been partners
with their ex
for 16 freaking years how pleasant is
this
and junior pays the bill
he can't get good credit but he seems to
pay this bill
this is like parent plus loan on
steroids when you're taking out a
mortgage for your kids so what would you
do in the alternative dave
well in the alternative i would
suggest that the young man rent
until he can get his crap together
and i'll be happy to pay him
pay for him to go to financial peace
university i'll pay for him to read a
book on money
from one of the many ramsey
personalities including me
i would uh even participate if he wanted
to get out of debt and was on a budget
and was being real
gung-ho i might even match him and say
for every thousand dollars you pay off
i'll pay a thousand for you
if you've got the money
and you want to help them get up and get
moving you're you're participating in
positive behaviors then that are going
to lead him to sustainability
not negative behaviors that allow him to
mask over and pretend like he doesn't
have a problem
and buying your kid a house and put it
in our mortgage in your name is just
straight up stupid
never do that
under any circumstances
let them go rent something and if you
want to write some checks you know write
some checks and help them that way
but you don't need to get in the home
ownership business with an irresponsible
kiddo
it's a bad plan it doesn't work out well
for them or for you it ends up the way
her her situation ends up it's sad yeah
it's really sad and we're all first
generation they really wanted to help
yeah and the problem is they defined the
word help wrong
and it wasn't real help instead of and
still look at them and going no
10 years from now you're still going to
be in a mess because you ain't going to
change until you change
you hadn't changed you know i mean it's
just that it's a mess yeah well it seems
like generosity you know we're big fans
of that around here absolutely if you're
generous in a way that doesn't help
someone get control of their life and
it's not a blessing to them then it
really wasn't generosity
even when you're being generous to a
charity
when you're giving to a charity that
mishandles money
all you're doing is participating in
their mishandling of the money
you just helped them do it
and so
you know we do
due diligence ramsey family foundation
before we give to charities we want to
make sure they're handling money well
that the money's actually going to help
the people it's not going to we don't
know how to run the office properly
and uh that some charities don't know
how to run the office property properly
and they end up spending 90 of the money
on overhead and 10 to help the starving
child or whatever it is they're supposed
to be doing you know and so it'd been
easier just to go feed some kids you
know you'd have been better off
and so you've got to use some good
common sense with this otherwise you're
participating and that is not being mean
and that's not being angry heartless
dave and it's not being heartless it's
not being tough
it's none of those things it's actual
love
i love you so much i'm not going to
participate in your misbehavior
i can't be a party to your misbehavior
because i love you too much
i i will help you do positive things if
you want to do wonderful things i'm
going to walk with you i'll be your
biggest cheerleader i might even write
some checks in the positive direction
but i'm not going to mask over
your misbehavior and start paying for
your stuff
well as the saying goes you entertain a
clown you join the circus exactly and so
that's what people find themselves in is
now i'm in i'm all looped into this
crazy and now i have resentment because
it didn't work out how i thought it was
going to work out and now i'm calling
this show and we have uh you know this
this current generation coming up um
in their early 20s mid-20s
is uh has got two types of people in it
unbelievably responsible and mature
beyond their years
and ones that are still living in their
mother's basement at 27 years old
and
moms
dads
kick them out
lovingly
give them a 90 day plan i'll walk with
you i'll coach you
we're going to assist you
but playing uh playing nintendo is not a
job
playing call of duty is not a job
you need to go get a life
you're stunting your kids growth
emotionally by allowing them to exist in
your basement at 26 or 36 years old
now short term that's fine a safety net
is fine but a safety hammock is not a
plan we don't want a crutch yeah i mean
listen an eagle that doesn't leave the
nest is eventually known as a turkey
okay this is how this works so these are
these are enabling situations you're not
being helpful now some people got kicked
out of the house in angry rage-filled
ways or toxic family situations and
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
gonna love you so much i'll help you
move the couch
i'm gonna love you so much i'm gonna
have taught you to work from the time
you were five years old until the time
you were 20 and then you actually know
what work looks like you know what a
callus is other than on your thumbs
you know and so you know it's just i'm
going to love you so well that you are
sustainable as an adult and you will
have dignity long after i'm gone
and there's no dignity in being a
parasite no there's just none
it doesn't it doesn't it's not helpful
to the parasite even
we got to stop raising kids and start
raising adults that's what i'm seeing
out there you're right there's a lot of
great adults out there but there's a lot
of kids yeah and it's not a it's not
this generation every generation has
done it
my generation had what they call them
the boomerangs you throw them out and
they come back
yeah
remember that one that's clever that was
good yeah oh man
gotta love it gotta love it
well we love you so much people we're on
your team we want you to win
and consequently we're going to tell you
the truth might hurt your feelings
but it'll help it's entertaining radio
too this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage chris and donya are with
us hey guys how are you hi hi good thank
you welcome where do you guys live
austin texas all right welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off we paid off 50 000. good for you how
long did that take about 18 months good
and your range of income during that
time well when we got started we were
about 50 000 and
not too long after we got started we
were up to 100 000. good what do you
guys do for a living i'm a ups driver
i own my own cleaning business okay so
how'd you double your income
uh it was uh a natural progression you
start as a
loader in the warehouse oh okay so you
got and and i'm guessing you got more
work to do yeah
more cleaning work
yeah okay good so yeah drivers make more
than loaders for sure yeah about two to
three times yeah yeah considerable more
yeah good way to go guys what kind of
debt was the 50k
we had credit card debt we had two cars
we had furniture
uh
oh i had a business that had gone under
several years past so i owed a bunch of
people that personally loaned me money
friends and family uh-huh
so you guys were like normal pretty
normal pretty normal yeah it kind of
sucks it was a mess
so you look up you got 50 000 worth of
mess how long y'all been married 10
years 10 years
but 18 months ago what happened what
what how'd the switch flip tell us your
story well our journey started a little
bit before 18 months ago as far as
getting our lives together so we've been
married for 10 years uh i found myself
down a uh pretty dark hole about
five years ago i was at a rock bottom to
the disease of addiction uh
so i got myself into 12 step recovery
and started putting my life together
taking responsibility for
my future our future
and uh good for you yeah thank you sir
so you've been sober for how long coming
up on five years way to go man i'm proud
of you thank you i appreciate that well
done what what did you kick what kind of
what kind of well i i pretty much used
anything i could get my hands on but it
was a methamphetamine that took me all
the way down to the bottom
that's a tough one to boss yes sir way
to go man super proud of you so
uh
we that was about a little less than
five years ago uh i started that journey
and
about
a year ago i heard uh you on well maybe
a little more than a year ago i heard
you on the megan kelly show oh yeah and
at this point my mind was clear enough
where i could actually say oh my gosh
this is the next thing i need to do i
told her i said hey we need to get on
this dave ramsey thing
and she's like oh my gosh beans and rice
yeah it doesn't sound very fun
but i had her listen to the episode and
then we got your book from the library
the audiobook i listened to it in one
listen basically
and it was off from there
so i sold all the single stocks we had
everything we had in savings and
put it uh all toward debt
uh
and then i didn't know what to do from
there i didn't know how to budget i
didn't know anything it was like
i have no idea what to do so i got up
the courage to call you
i called you and uh john deloney was on
the show and i i told you a little bit
of my story then and you gave me a year
of your uh ramsay plus all right yeah
and he told me to call back when we got
debt-free and so we decided we'd come
out and here you are
we love working with everybody out there
but i particularly love to get to be the
financial part art ramsey and the team
do we get to be the financial part of
the healing from a past like yours when
you can kick that and then you can step
over and clean up and go on really clean
life going forward that's awesome man
yes sir we're so proud of you we're so
honored to be part of your story i'm
honoring myself very cool well done well
done on the eve of john dolone's book
own your past change your future you're
living proof of that and what that looks
like i mean you changed so many parts of
your life you've got a beautiful family
was that your why what was the driving
force 18 months ago where he went no
more we can't live like this yeah it was
just all kind of natural progression of
cleaning cleaning up my past cleaning up
and
you know taking responsibility for life
i i think i heard dave say one time he
could either be a victim or a victor
and i was uh i was done being a victim
amen
cool that'll be don you got a whole new
man that you did six years ago yeah i do
he's a completely different guy
i'm so grateful hey man hey man god's
been good to y'all well done so proud of
you wow absolutely amazing
all right so uh actually the getting out
of debt thing is no big deal compared to
the other stuff but but uh but it is a
big deal because it's one of the details
the nuanced details i guess of the whole
story so what do you all tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
i don't think we could have done it
without the budget app and that was a
part that i was most stuck on and once
we got that you know we talked to two
coaches through the ramsey plus and we
took the courses and we just started
doing it and once we started doing it
was like oh there's too much money going
there there's not enough money going
here let's start telling our money what
to do
and uh it was we found about two
thousand dollars a month that we could
start throwing at the debt and it was
from there it was
uh just doing it and that's what we did
well done y'all very well done your
heroes so proud of both of you thank you
proud of you for sticking with him
and i'm proud of him for doing the hard
work yeah very well done
and and to the question of the why it
was keeping the family you know like it
was i came to a point where i wasn't
allowed to come home i was staying on my
truck and i was like
this is
worth it like whatever i thought i had
going for me it wasn't you know like i
needed my family i needed her i needed
the kids to
uh to know i know how to be a man yeah
so she told you don't go home home do
you clean up then huh yeah good for you
that was a hard call
yes hard call but it worked out it did
worked out good good for you you guys
are tough
you're tough as nails man you've worked
through some real stuff both of you man
very very powerful wow you guys are my
hero of the day man excellent just so
cool
very very cool
yeah so let's bring the kiddos up what
are their names and ages we've got
isaiah and eva
isaiah's seven and eva's five oh man
perfect ages very well done good looking
kiddos too well done you guys well we
have a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure no stopping you guys
you're warriors man how to or how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too and also a copy
of the total money makeover for you to
give away and stir somebody up out there
stir up a holy ruckus just keep this
moving man keep paying it forward well
done you guys so proud of you man
they're cool i know it reminds me of the
quote getting a testimony uh well having
a testimony is great getting one sucks
yeah
getting ones and you have such an
inspiring story to share with other
people now as you hand that book over
you say man this thing was a part of
life change for me and i hope it does
the same for you yeah that's powerful
good for you guys all right chris and
donya isaiah and eva 50 000 bucks paid
off in 18 months making 50 to 100 the
every dollar app stepped in gotta love
it count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
man don't tell me you can't change your
life
mean he's living proof man
you know we just did that whole segment
uh on enabling and this is the exact
opposite she says don't come home yeah
and he's in the truck
and he wakes up and goes uh-uh those
babies in that girl are worth it i gotta
straighten up and then he starts the
process of coming clean that's powerful
that's the truest form of love that's
powerful that's um
that's hard hard stuff it's a very hard
situation to find yourself into being on
both both sides of that coin but uh the
net result is a beautiful family right
here a beautiful future she's got a
great job now man life is good she does
she's kicking it with her business it's
just incredible very very well done some
family and we get to be a little tiny
part of the story with ramsay plus and
then with financial peace university and
with
the every dollar app and all to help
them with this last part of some of the
cleanup so very well done man
that's about as good as it gets ma come
down here every day george that's why we
do it live is good never gets old
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture today genesis 28 15 i am
with you and will watch over you
wherever you go and i will bring you
back to this land i will not leave you
until i've done what i promised you
our greatest weakness thomas edison said
lies in giving up
the most certain way to succeed is
always to try just one more time george
i like that
reminds me of uh your quote success is a
pile of failures that you're just
standing on
it reminds me of that that's what
success is
that's good
well it's a matter of uh course
corrections or mistakes or whatever but
learning from them standing on them
rather than laying
under them is the process for sure
well tax season ends
today april the 18th if you're filing
online which is 95 percent of you if you
need affordable tax software that you
can trust that isn't trying to sell you
a bunch of debt or isn't trying to up
charge you with a bunch of hidden fees
you can use ramsey smart tax instead of
those other guys super easy to use
you'll get every federal form that you
need no hidden fees use the promo code
tax 22 and you get 25 off filing your
federal return that means you get our
federal classic software for free
or you can get the federal premium
software with priority support and a
financial coaching session all for just
20 bucks if you use the promo code tax
22. it's a bargain it's a deal it's easy
way to file your taxes
ramsey smart tax
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
smart tax chris is in fort worth hey
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hey george hey dave how you all doing
better than we deserve what's up
love that um i want to set up my
two-year-old for success
she might be a doctor one day or she
might start a llama farm but i wanted
her to be able to do both of those depth
for you
um
so 16 years from now she'll probably be
ready for college or not
and based on what georgia said in the
past if we kind of reverse engineer it i
think i might need 400 000 it's just a
number i came up with
um and i know that the s p 500 does 12
percent a year on average and so if i
put 60 in today and nothing else at 12
it comes up to 400
or i can throw that down to my mortgage
i just kind of want to know what you
guys think i should do in my situation
well i think you can do both you can pay
off the house early and we can fully
fund
her college i feel like there's a lot of
ifs and if this happens in 16 years from
now versus just consistently investing a
little bit into the college fund paying
some on the house you don't need to do
this all in one lump sum
i'm fine with you checking the box um
and being done with it if you want to
call that done here's what will happen
in reality nothing works out exactly
like you're planning in 20 years from
now
as a matter of fact nothing works out
exactly like you're planning it 20 years
from now
and so you know i don't know exactly
what's going to go down here but if you
want to drop
a chunk of some kind
maybe you're only put in
uh 40 and you're going to end up with
300 i don't know whatever it is
or you end up with less or you end up
with more depending on the performance
of the market we don't know exactly what
it's going to do
but uh
you know it's a reasonable projection
the point is you're going to be building
wealth by the time she gets to school
you're going to have wealth in addition
to this and a paid for house
so you're going to be fine i mean
it's uh but the good news is if you want
to check that box at baby step five and
say i'm gonna put x number of dollars in
lump sum and be done with college
funding
check box checked let's go get you a
good um
you know 529 plan where you're choosing
the options pick good mutual fund
options in there and head at it nothing
wrong with that at all
and then just tear at the house next or
throw it down on the house and like
george said just go steady into the baby
step five either one
is
fine
either one's
fine i did never have a llama farm on
the list of things to do though
um nothing wrong is that a career choice
nothing wrong with that
llama farm wasn't on my list i didn't
i'm a camel man myself
as you could have guessed oh i don't
know oh there's so much wrong with that
i can't go there because i'll get
arrested adam is in san antonio hey adam
welcome to the ramsey show
hey there mr randy how are you doing
today great man what's up
hey i had a question for you sir and uh
first i wanted to say thank you so much
for your time um i used to be myself 114
000 in debt in 2017 three years and two
months later it's paid off way to go man
awesome yes sir
thank you so much yeah thanks to you and
a cousin i have named kevin who uh
always kept talking about you i stopped
being stubborn one day and gave that way
okay i appreciate it sir
yes sir
and um i wanted to ask you a question
i've listened to your show quite a few
times and i haven't i'm sure there's an
instance and i probably missed it but um
my mom is 68 and i just wanted to ask on
her behalf your advice so she hasn't
saved for retirement um
she has 18 000 in her 401k
um 60k in cash
her home is valued i think approximately
in the low 500s right now and she owes
about 205 on it
and
she's at that point right now i've been
watching it happen for a while where
eventually it was going to get to this
point of you know what do i do next and
so
um tried to talk to my mom about it but
she she didn't want to talk about it so
you can only talk to someone if they
want to talk about it so i just wanted
to ask your advice sir she asked me for
some advice this morning and
you know i think probably the lord put
you on my mind so i just thought i would
call in and just get your advice and
see what you do if you're in this
situation
wow that's a tough one man
uh how much does she make
she's making about 70 000 right now she
hit past the normal retirement age for
social security so she's able to
take the social security benefit while
still being able to work um full-time so
she's been bringing in from that that's
an additional
um
2000 or 2200 a month on top of the base
is she doing right now
she is a nurse a registered nurse
used to work in the hospital running the
or but now that's too physically
intensive on her so right now she's
doing some medical claims billing work
um
working from home that require
uh that she can still do you know allows
her to sit and so forth
okay
well i mean
the same principles the same principles
apply
we've got to get her out of that and
build an emergency fund and build a
nest egg
and i don't know how we're going to do
that on this income
at this age
um
it's not impossible
but the uh um
you know my guess is she's probably
going to downsize in house
and where does she live
she lives in uh weatherford texas in the
dallas fort worth area okay
um if i could find a three hundred
thousand dollar condo that i could pay
cash for
and move her out of that house that'd be
if i were her
i'd look at doing that and let's get the
housing paid for then all we've got to
do is just pile up cash with the
remaining work gears for nest egg
yes sir i don't know how you're going to
support a 205 000 mortgage on social
security
yes sir um if you don't mind me asking
one brief question on top of that it's
still tied to the exact same issue
um
my brother-in-law has quite a bit of
land and did offer her uh to possibly
build a tiny home on that land
um
now you have to build a tiny home you
got 300 grand
right
right i wouldn't build i wouldn't build
it to hold on to no i wouldn't build a
tiny home because there's no there's no
no resale for them there's no market
proven it's a fad
it may prove out later to not be a fad
but for right now it's a fad because
there's no resale on them
yes sir
so i want to i want to do real estate
deals that go up in value and then i can
live in long long term but for a couple
hundred thousand bucks she could put a
really nice property if he'll donate the
land to her
sell the house take some of the equity
and build a nice house a good house
doesn't have to be a tiny house and it's
paid for then
it needs to be deeded to her the
property needs to be deeded to her
so he needs to cut out a parcel a acre
or something and give mom an acre and
then she builds a house on it uh by the
and uses the proceeds to sell from hers
that'll help a lot
and if she built that for 200 then she's
got an extra 100 because she's got 300
equity throw that in there to start her
nest egg and then pile on that nest take
george that'll work yeah i'm not relying
on social security though to fund my
retirement and not with a 200 000
mortgage that house is gone it's not
gonna make this cut
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you